i was born in brooklyn my father was a
new york city firefighter
my mother was a homemaker uh back in the
60s when i was born
that was a act considered a full-time
job my dad
joined the fire department in 1963
and in 1964 he took his family from
brooklyn the flats in brooklyn on
brighton marine parkway
and flatlands avenue and he took us to
brentwood new york it was a new
burgeoning community that many of the
new york city workers found themselves
moving out to was affordable it was a
home with the backyard and at this point
we had i think there was five of us
and my next brother ended up being born
out there in in long island and then my
sister so we had a total of seven kids
we grew up in a what you consider back
then a typical irish-american family
dad being a firefighter and mom uh
raising us
i ended up
with a passion for sports
my dad
had uh focused us on um well all sports
but particularly we ended up being
involved in ice hockey
uh we love the new york rangers
brad park
was one of my favorite rangers jill bear
hatfield so the we called it the gag
line back then so as you can see i was
passionate about hockey
and uh
from that point on
we had our own basically our own team we
had seven
seven uh siblings that could play the
sports
some better than others um
and and it took it took a while to
realize that uh
i wasn't going to be a professional
athlete
so at some point um which wasn't very
quick but i i'll be honest i i held on
to that dream probably up until 11th
grade in high school when i realized
that i just wasn't big enough and strong
enough and fast enough but between
between
uh
10 years old and 17 years old i had a
very slow growth rate i was one of those
slow irish growers so
it took me a while to fill out and um
which which sort of uh made me um
it made me feel less than uh it was one
of those things that i had to go through
as a young
adolescent
and i still trying to i'm still trying
to overcome it today um
i was a late bloomer i was very
interested in dating and no one wanted
to date a late bloomer um
so i i i would say
it went into a lot into formulating who
i would become as a young adult
and
i think from that point forward
realizing that i was a slow bloomer
it limited my athletic involvement
because i certainly wasn't able to excel
uh mentally i was
acute and aware and and pretty good at
things and physically i had skills but i
wasn't powerful enough yet so it set me
back and and i'm i'm talking about this
because it was a very formative time of
my life that sort of would be the bridge
to the rest of my life at that because
of the shortcomings that i faced as a
young guy my best friends were powerful
young athletes and i was was gifted like
them in skills but not not capable of
staying with them because of my lack of
physical strength
so as you can tell i'm focusing on this
because it was a big part of my youth
and it was a very disappointing part for
me
so as i as i went along in life i i
became
i began to make choices based on
my insecurities and being insecure i
began every time i i dated someone i
latched on to them like it was my last
date ever
and and it was very informative and
formative to me
i married my first girlfriend
in fact the reason
i went from high school to college to be
an accountant my mother asked me to stay
in college
and finish my accounting and get my
accounting degree but i chose because i
wanted to keep my girlfriend and marry
her i chose to take the new york city
police department test amongst other
civil service tests and from there
i chose to
take the police department when they
called me
and and then shortly thereafter
mary impregnate my girlfriend and then
and then end up marrying her uh
it was almost uh at that point in my
life i realized that i i was
the man that i wanted to be physically
mentally or maybe not mentally i maybe
i'm still not still not sure that i am
that man mentally but you know i could i
i at that point in my life i was able to
be
um
physically and and financially secure
and now i ended up marrying a woman who
i loved
but it was puppy love still it was my
first love and uh
many of us know in the world today that
those relationships tend to not work out
it's your first girlfriend it's your
first experience in life
and you end up marrying them and it was
a very difficult struggling match for me
as i entered the police academy her and
i was still in the dating scene
she promised she would never marry a
police officer and i was like why i
didn't understand why at the time
and as it turned out i began to know why
as a police officer you're exposed to a
lot of different things
and women are way more mature than men
they're more way more astute than men
she knew that there'd be opportunities
coming my way that would be difficult
for me to resist and so
she was right once again as most women
are she was definitely right it was
difficult to resist certain things and
there was some
lack of fidelity to say the least as i
was growing up
and so yes what led to a challenging
beginning to a relationship um
so
i went to the police academy
and as i entered the police academy i
was scared
i was a 20 year old 20 i just turned 21.
i was a young guy i thought i was going
to have a burgeoning hockey career that
didn't work out in fact i'll tell you a
story
on my way into the police academy i
badly
twisted my ankle and i couldn't tell you
which one today it was
i think it was the right but it could
have been the left either way
so i was so excited that i was going to
start the police academy and the day
before i started it i twisted my ankle
so
i ran the entire police academy with a
black and blue ankle and i didn't miss a
lap and didn't miss a step but i was in
pain for like a solid eight months and
for about two three years my ankle was
never recovered right but that's how
that's how scared i was to
to admit that i had an injury i didn't
want to lose the job i didn't want to
lose the opportunity to become a police
officer at the same time i was scared to
death to be a police officer because i
didn't know what i would face
and not only did i know what i faced my
physical
my physicality was just starting to
catch up to me so i really i was i was
between a boy and a man at 20 21 years
old and it was scary physically scary
mentally and emotionally i felt less
than
so i really was it was a challenging
time for me
and
it turned out that uh while in the
police academy i put on like 20 or 25
pounds go figure right it's like you see
the kid go up to the marine corps and he
comes home a man well sure enough it
just took me a couple years later than
the 18 year old going off to the service
so between 21 and 22 years old i really
began to fill out and become much more
physical physically capable i was a very
strong kid but i was i was a bait clamor
as a child as a child as a young man i
was a bait cleaner between 18 and 20
years old i clammed in the great south
bay so what that gave me was core
strength for a young lean man and then
as i filled in it really it was really
and i'm focusing on this because it's a
very important part of being a police
officer you can't be a little weasely
guy and handle the streets of brooklyn
back in the 80s i assure you
and now i'm officially a cop
and and i'm not ready
i'm just not ready i'm i'm scared
so they send me to queens i get this
slow birthing in queens they send me out
on patrol my first day on patrol in
queens they have no radios
so now i'm a police officer who's still
a little scared
i'm under the l on roosevelt avenue if
you're familiar with queens at all it's
it's a dark danky place and and
and it's a hustle and bustle and
i'm still this kid from long island
who's not sure what day it is and i'm
standing there and i need
to have a quarter in my pocket
in case something goes down because
i don't have a police radio i'm going to
bang on the street with my stick no
one's going to hear me
so
to say the least i was unnerved and
scared and i'm saying to myself is this
for me i'm standing out here
and i don't feel like i should be doing
this i want to quit in fact it comes to
a point where i turn around and i'm
going back to the precinct i walk in the
precinct and the lieutenant at the desk
says to me dowd i go yes sir you know
well worried what did i do now he goes
do me a favor when you're standing out
there under the l
try not to scare the public getting
phone calls
that you're out there with your hand on
your gun he says it's going to happen he
says but you really don't want to get
known for like scaring the public your
first week out there so for unbeknownst
to me i was scaring the public that was
scaring me on my first freaking day on
patrol
anyway as as so as the story would go i
would get more comfortable
uh and then i would then the reality hit
and and i graduated what they call the
training portion of my
of my police career and i ended up
getting transferred to brooklyn east new
york brooklyn and let me tell you i tell
the story and i'll tell it for your
audience
i'm driving in to east new york brooklyn
now i got about a year and a half as a
police officer i've seen some action
nothing too heavy a couple doas
a couple of arrests nothing major and
i'm driving down sutter avenue and it's
6 30 in the morning june 13th 1983
and
i look to my right and there's a group
of people out throwing dice
against a wall of a bodega
and
in the ghetto comes on by elvis presley
and if anybody knows that song i can't
sing it that well but if i could for if
you played the music i'd sing it for you
and a young man
dies and the mother cries and and i'm
crying
i am filled up with tears in my eyes i
want to turn around and go home now i'm
a year and a half as a police officer
and i want to go home i don't want to do
this this is scary as [ __ ]
i'm going into the ghetto
and
i i go to my locker i fill my locker up
with my uniform and my equipment
and i'm i'm exacerbated i don't know
what to do
so of course i go i stand roll call
and i'm wondering how's this going to
turn out for me i'm not comfortable
i'm fearful
and
i would say
there came a point and one of my first
scenes was a shooting you go figure east
new york brooklyn 7-5 precinct deadliest
precinct in the country and one of my
first scenes is a shooting scene it's on
a midnight shift
and i had i had almost tossed these two
individuals because they were carrying a
tire iron
at two in the morning three in the
morning what are you doing with a tire
iron you're robbing cars you're doing
something you're robbing tires back then
it was big to rob tires because it was
good in the crack error or the the drug
error you can get a 50 60 bucks quick
for some tires back then so
and i
and i failed to stop them because my
partner didn't want to get out of the
car
and then three blocks i passed three
blocks i turn around and i
as i turn back around i see a guy laying
in the street with a hole in his [ __ ]
head and he was in front of a kuchifito
place back then which we called which
would have been a
it's an all-night
dominican spot where you can get
anything you need to eat drink maybe
even sex if you could whatever whatever
goes on in those places
and there's a guy laying in the street
and the place had emptied out and
standing around and here is jesus his
name is jesus jesus is shot in the
street in east new york i'm probably on
the job a week or two and i'm like this
is real i almost stopped somebody
that had a weapon on them a gun
and in this case instead of shooting me
he shot jesus
and i'm like how profound is like this
is going through my mind i'm like this
is this is real like this is no joke
here someone's dead
and i
almost stopped this person and it could
have been me
so some people might out there might say
it should have been you but in this case
it you know thankfully it wasn't so
that's the start of my career in east
new york and i said to myself mr dowd
you're going to either sink or you're
going to swim
so it's time for you to it's time for
you to step up and be the man that
you're supposed to be and and and i
fought through those insecurities the
late blooming aspect of it where i had
to struggle with my own identity you
know uh not as male female thing don't
get me wrong here but about you know my
abilities as a man to handle
confrontation i mean we're not knowing
superman here you know you don't get an
s on your chest when you graduate the
police academy and you know everything's
invincible and you can handle arnold
schwarzenegger
down to minnie mouse it doesn't work
that way you know you train you stay in
shape and you hopefully you can handle
yourself
uh so p.s that's how my career began so
now i i realize i'm in the depths of
this career and i'm embracing it now i'm
about to get married to a woman that i
should have probably not married even
though she was a wonderful person i
wasn't ready for it
so a lot of things are going on in my
life i'm i'm i'm a young police officer
beginning a burgeoning career i think i
think it's going to be a successful one
i have no idea that i'm going to end up
where i end up in my career at this
point i'm enjoying being a police
officer i'm making arrests i'm making
drug arrests i'm making murder arrests
i'm making rape arrests i can go i can
go down the list of the type of arrests
i made and how i was being actually
wanted as a valuable young police
officer in the 7-5 for my first year and
a half
and um
so i'll tell a story so i come into the
um precinct one day and i see all these
guys with their medals and you know
young cops want to get medals above
their badge because two things it shows
you've got some street credibility and
two it wipes away the the newness to to
you being on the street and everybody
wants to have a little bit of salt on in
there in their jeans or or in their
uniform uh when they when they're facing
the street that's pretty salty
it gives it even gives the uh what's
called
uh
the street guys or or or the perps
you get some credibility when you got
some metal stacked above your badge so
who doesn't want that off the rip you
know it it sort of mitigates that that
hey here's a new jack approach from the
street guys
so i go into the captain's office he
calls i wrote up three or four medals
and he looks at me and he goes to me
you made a rape caller you took two guns
off the street you made a drug caller
and you did something else that was
really pretty good he says to me
this is east new york
he said this is a regular day
what was it doubt this is a regular day
i said excuse me i go i took two guns
off the street all on observation they
weren't like calls
the rape collar and then there was there
was one other one that was a drug collar
it was a big drug caller he goes to me
doubt he says i'll tell you what i'll
give you one meritorious an epd the
other two i can't help you with so it
was like it was monty hall i was making
a deal with the captain just so i can
get a
you know what they call medals uh uh or
some
above my above my badge and
and i said you know
i felt like a fool and here i am a young
aggressive cop i think i'm doing
something really good i'm making these
really exciting arrests i'm getting
pat's on the back by the my fellow
officers i go into the cap and he says
this is a regular day in east new york
i'm like wait a minute well if i was in
queens or staten island or midtown
manhattan what would i be doing oh you'd
be getting you'd be getting you know
gold plate dinners awards for these
types of arrests but not in east new
york well it's a regular day so
what an awakening to say the least
so is
so now i'm faced i'm in a i'm i'm in a
precinct and i'm in a crew i'm beginning
a career that's showing me
what i think is so important and so big
has
mitigation and value it might have been
important to the person's life i helped
save or the woman i prevented being
continuously raped that may have been
important to them but you know as far as
the pd was concerned and the bureaucracy
and what we call the job you know the
job really didn't give a [ __ ] about me
or
what i was doing it was more like it was
a numbers game for them and it became a
numbers game and so that takes away
my policing instinct not to for the
instinctiveness of it but to to sort of
hold some pride in what i was doing it
it got wiped away real quickly when when
you didn't feel the sense of um
your own department showing you that
they appreciate your excellent work
uh so so that's where the rub starts to
meet the road very early on in your
career and um
so so things start to change my outlook
on the police department and how and
don't get me wrong just because they
didn't give me a medal isn't the reason
there's it's a sequence of things that
are going on you know you got to stop
making drug arrests because
you're clogging up the system you know
they have to be significant if you make
a couple of crack bile arrests
you know you're costing the city
thousands of dollars in in housing and
inmate and processing an arrest overtime
for you
you're off the street there's less
cops out as visible cops supposed to be
visible so that they can prevent crime
by their visibility
so it it became became a
self-fulfilling prophecy of doom and
and and
and one way spiral downward in both
my mind
in in society because you're now
encouraging the police officers to stop
making arrests you're not ordering them
to stop making arrests you're just
making their lives more difficult if
they make arrests
so it became
a very combative way to go to work and
to do your job
that's where michael dowd begins to turn
his own
he starts to make the job as a police
officer his own
reward
um
post so in other words rather than going
to work
to do the job as a police officer that
i'm supposed to be doing
i begin to do the job where it benefits
me
and that's not to say i didn't know my
job and handled my jobs correctly you
know and appropriate and professionally
but anytime i can take a little leeway
that would benefit me which might have
been whether it's a free meal or i need
new windows in my house so i go see the
window guy in the precinct or i need a
new front door on my house or i need
paint for my house you know i begin to
utilize the job to my benefit
and then after that slowly becomes a way
of doing the job
i end up
starting to look for some money
and and and and and and i think i've
told the story a thousand times how i
come across what they call the puerto
rican mystery back in the day
whether
because the puerto ricans didn't need
papers when they came to america so they
so they didn't bring any you know so
they came here as citizens but they
didn't have licenses they they
oftentimes didn't register their
vehicles because i think that the and i
don't know but i think in puerto rico if
you if you're if you knew the neighbor
they didn't tell the police and he never
you never had an issue like that things
were run differently in puerto rico than
they were in new york but the guys from
puerto rico who came to new york sort of
ran it the same way they didn't have
registrations often on their vehicles so
we called them the puerto rican mystery
it was just the way the street spoke i
learned it from others and and and i
share the story openly and honestly
because they became my best friends and
i l and i love my puerto ricans but in
fact half of my family's gotten hispanic
and puerto rican roots in them
but but but that's how they were and
that's how we were trained as cops
though that's a puerto rican mystery so
it was good for four tickets
so i find this guy i'm gonna give him
four tickets maybe even have to take his
vehicle because it's not registered
and i don't want to do this to this kid
because he's really not a bad kid you
know he just he just didn't have the
paperwork right
he owned the vehicle he the title was
signed to his name
and now he's got he's got a corvette
it's like a 78 corvette this is 1984.
i mean so it's really not an old car you
know and so it's probably a fifteen
thousand dollar vehicle at the time and
he's got a lot of hundreds in his bag
so i could take his car
or leave him with uh or leave him with
his car and get a few hundred for myself
so i made a decision and and sure enough
i said we'd like to how about a nice
lobster lunch for me and my partner i
need him to say give me cash
i said you know a nice lobster lunch
would do and we can and let this thing
go by so he put some money on the back
seat i couldn't tell you if it was 200
500
i know it wasn't five
or seventy five dollars all i know is
you put some money on the back seat of
my car
and i felt like i felt like i i felt
like i won something i felt like i won a
prize
so
from that moment forward i decided if i
don't get in trouble for this which i
didn't i'm going to just look for small
opportunities
to enrich myself
and i began to find ways to do it
and at this point i'm making about
22 to 24 000 a year and my partner's
taking these plastic vials with rocks in
them and throwing them out we don't know
what they are i mean there'd be a tennis
ball and i'd be bouncing the tennis ball
see now people don't know but you can
bounce a tennis ball with a hole in it
especially if it's cut on the scene
and he could still bounce it so this guy
bouncing his tennis ball and
finally i grabbed a tennis ball on this
kid one day i squeeze the tennis ball
and it opens up and there's a bunch of
plastic things in vials and with rocks
i'm saying is we don't know what it is
and
so we throw it out we fig we know it's
not legal whatever we don't know what it
is no one's told us yet that this is
crack cocaine and this is a crime we
know it probably is but we don't even
know where we're going with it it just
hit the street we don't know so one day
we find out that it has great value
through another observation that we did
someone took a sewer cover plate off to
get the crack vials out that we threw
down we said if someone's lifting a
400-pound sewer plate to get the crack
vials out from this sewer there must be
a lot of value to these things so the
next day my partner and i find a
marlborough box or a newport i think it
was newport because the ghetto they they
prefer newport i think so so he took a
he took a newport box home filled with
crack files he come back the next day he
hands me two three hundred dollars i
said what the [ __ ] is this for he goes
that stuff i brought home last night
turns out to be crack cocaine it's worth
a lot of money
i mean we've been throwing it out for
about two months now
so i mean thousands of dollars worth of
stuff we've thrown out now oh jesus
christ this is like an atm machine now
we've got money in the street every day
we're like
we've become
essentially a crack dealer my we would
take the crack from the crack that we
found in the street my partner would
take it home he'd come back to work and
hand me a couple hundred every couple
days so at the end of the week instead
of making the 315 a week i was making
with the pd clear
i was making two to 300 a day
on every day we hit something so you're
talking i was double and tripling my
salary in just one little small score
like that so it became
it became the job for us
of course we still did our job the
police work is police work but when we
saw an opportunity to take a little
something we did it and our life
was enriched i mean my partner redid his
whole home
on the street money that we took you
know and of course i i just we funny
story my partner says to me one day
i really need to i need about a month
off i said for what he says to fix my
house
he says i need to and he takes his hand
and he's holding his hand like this he
says if i could break this finger
i could still hold the hammer so he i
take my flashlight and i smash his hand
he doesn't even know him
i just go
bang i smash his finger he goes what the
[ __ ] i said you said you wanted a broken
finger and he puts his hand back up and
i hit it again with the flashlight bang
i go i think it's broken now
he's like holy [ __ ] i said listen i'm
sick of you talking about it it's done
he goes in he gets it x-ray it's broken
he takes a month off to heal his finger
and he fixed his house up with the money
he'd been making on the side i went out
and worked for him a couple days i did a
little bit of work around the house for
him and sure enough he was out and he
lived out in mastic at the time mastic
beach
so we redid his house in mastic beach on
the crack money and a broken finger so
it was quite the experience for him and
uh he saved a lot of money doing himself
but but the point is that
we began to look at the job for what we
can get from it i mean while we're
public servants you're not supposed to
be doing that you're supposed to be
there serving the public oh whoever
thought that we'd be serving ourselves
so that was the beginning of my career
on how i would end up it down the down
the road to where i end up so
but during this process
before i end up in big time with the
with the big kingpins
i'm i'm going i'm going home at night to
a miserable home life because i'm not
focused on it i have a brand new baby
i'm not honest i'm hurting myself
my current wife at the time
um
is is not happy with my let's say
performance in i'm not i'm not acting
like i'm not acting like the man young
boy young man whatever it was that she
knew when i was 17. um hostile i'm short
i'm not considerate
i have money that i never had so of
course men and money sometimes they act
a little differently i wasn't respecting
my relationship
and
i began to become somebody that i didn't
like
and
i it i ended up not being able to
separate that nasty prick that had to
run the street
from the loving caring human being i
should be at home
they became sort of the same person
and
that's no way to live a life and it's no
way to share a life with somebody so so
my personality
begins to get formed by my actions my
survival skills
and my insecurities they're all meshing
into one now
and
there comes a point here
where i look in the mirror
and i go i don't like that [ __ ] guy i
was ashamed
and that was right around the time that
i had moved from brentwood long island
to port chef station long island so so
it's i'm getting advanced in my career
now but i shouldn't say that so i'm
sorry let me back up it was prior to
that that i started to feel that way but
it was more poignant to me as i got
older because i decided at some point
here
that i want to be more than a police
officer not that it's not
an honorable profession and it is and i
never took it that way that's why
i wanted to be more than that because i
never gave the police job the respect
deserved i never i never i never felt
honored to be a police officer which i
should have
and when i looked in that mirror i saw a
fake
and it was really beginning to bother me
the problem is that my whole life
at that point from
23 to like say 27 i was a fake
and it became part of who i was and i
couldn't separate myself from it easily
anymore
and i had a decision to make
and it's sad because i ultimately made
the wrong decision
i recognized that i wanted i wanted to
be a politician i'd go figure i wanted
to be a politician i thought that would
be an honorable way to serve my
community i know what communities need
because as a police officer you see
everything from the ground level up
and and i i grew up
a poor white guy you know seven kids my
father was a fireman what do you think
we had you know we shared shoes
we swapped them you grew out of them i
grew into them you know so you know we
had a rough upbringing when it come to
you know we didn't have white privilege
but what we had was each other
and i felt by being this person that
i've become i'm i felt like i wasn't
even one of my family
i felt detached from my family while i
was very involved with my family i felt
dirty inside so i wasn't really one of
them anymore so it was a very lonely
feeling
i couldn't be a politician because i was
afraid to run now for political i think
i could have won because i have a little
charisma i think i might i think i could
have i could have pulled it off but i
knew that at some point some of the
darkness would come out about the things
that i had done now you're raised to a
public level you know and people start
whenever i mean
some of the you think the most cleanest
politicians in the world you find out
the affairs of their life and they wish
they never ran i think we all know who
they are or who they've been you know go
back to gary hart i think his name is
whatever go back there right i mean just
that's not too far back and you'll
probably go further back but so going
back to there i knew that i would
jeopardize
my family's position my parents position
because their son
some disparaging things might be said
about him
so
it's sort of like i i was resigned at
that point i was like my shoulders
dropped and said now what
and i actually honestly said i'm gonna
have to be a damn good corrupt cop now
like that's what i said instead of
saying i'm gonna straighten my life out
and become a straight cop
but let me pause i did try at one point
when i when i was they tried to kill me
at my house one day a cop
uh a cop threatened to kill me and it's
it's a segway story that people don't
know about some do some who've listened
to me know about it but it's a story and
i can get into it briefly
i was transferred to coney island for
the summer detail on the summer detail a
guy started yelling yo yo yo from
nowhere from behind me and no carpet is
right if he's worth any street
credibility ever turns for a yo yo yo
man
so but as as the guys i can feel his
breath and his foot prince footsteps
getting closer and closer i glance back
and there's a big black guy jacked with
gold chains hanging around his neck i
figured as a local drug dealer yo yo yo
in me i'm glad i didn't turn
turned out he was a new york city cop
and a long story short i'll cut to the
chase and this because it's it's very
involved
he ends up putting a complaint in
against me a civilian complaint
are you [ __ ] kidding me
cops don't make complaints against other
cops
so after he makes his complaint against
me two weeks later you won't believe
this story he's out by my house in a
crackdown
on long island brentwood long island
route 111 right by the train station on
route 111 long island i like to give
location it gives people a little
reference
and above the above the dry cleaner
there was a crack house in 1986
and he was going in it
so
full disclosure i called internal
affairs on
i mean a guy just put a complaint in
against me i'm not i don't need to be
loyal to this guy you know you're loyal
to those that are loyal to you i think
everybody in the world would understand
that so
actually i didn't i actually wasn't
going to call internal affairs but my
neighbor who was the detective
in the in the 102 precinct said you
gotta he said you know here's a guy
selling now here i am just got finished
chain i stopped selling
the crack that we were stealing from the
street
and now i'm about to report a guy it's
killing me so that's part of that
twisted guy i was looking at in the
mirror it's killing me that i'm doing
this but i i justified it because he put
a complaint in against me he he tried to
be fired so yeah that's what you get
from me i'm you know i'm being honest
that's what you get from me you're going
to get me fired i'm going to [ __ ] you
any way i can too so p.s
i dropped the dime on him and lo and
behold internal affairs in new york city
like any other leaky leaky's faucet
all of a sudden within within weeks i'm
getting death threats at my house
turns out it was him
and and one day i'm on the phone he
wouldn't speak he'd call me up and just
hang up after about 15 minutes every day
for months
it was about two months he was going
finally i get him to talk
i go why don't you just come and we're
here and we do it and he goes how about
i put a [ __ ] bullet in your head
right now he says to me as i'm on the
phone at 2 30 3 o'clock in the morning i
just got in from my uh
i was doing 10 i was doing six to twos
in coney island at the time
how about i put a bullet in your [ __ ]
head right now through the window that
you're standing in front of
oh [ __ ] i look to my left i'm standing
in front of a window with the phone in
my hand so i just hit the ground i mean
what would you do i hit the ground i
said damn
i could do a better job vacuuming this
[ __ ]
because the sand and the rug i could
feel i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm crawling
across the rug trying to get behind the
wall here
my wife's in the other room screaming
what's going on i'm gonna shut the [ __ ]
up i'm yelling at her she's not the
problem because she's yelling he's on
the phone laughing ha ha ha i've been
[ __ ] your wife for months she's
telling me stories i'm like what
she's like who's [ __ ] me for months
i'm like just let him talk please i'm
trying to figure out who he is sure
enough i figured out who he was
i called the pd to pd says ah well we'll
put extra patrols
good luck you know
because they didn't care the pd i i to
be fair new york city police department
called suffolk county where i was living
and they said can you put a portable
radio in the office's house he's being
threatened they didn't know it was a cop
threatening me but they knew i was being
threatened suffolk county says that
we'll give them extra patrols
yeah so so instead of driving by once a
day they drove by twice a day you know
yeah there's 24 hours in the day but
they drove by twice a day now anyway so
i i lived under this this this is back
in like 86-87 i lived under this
dichotomy if you want to call it it was
a very odd way to live you know
i was a cop i i was a good cop i became
a bad cop i wanted to become a good cop
the cops didn't like me because now
they're not sure why i'm becoming a good
cop
the other guy the other guy threatens to
kill me i'm like this is [ __ ] this is
not what i bargained for i'm looking in
the mirror at a guy that's dirty
i don't want to be that guy anymore i
got a young child i want to be a dad to
this boy
you know and i have a woman there who's
you know doing her best to stand by me
and
and i'm a piece of [ __ ]
i've done bad i haven't paid for it i'm
trying to turn over a new leap no one's
letting me become the good cop mike
anymore they'd rather me be the bad cop
mike because that's what they're used to
cops are running out of the job because
the 7-7 precinct's getting locked up 13
of them get arrested they're all looking
at all the other cops around the whole
brooklyn north is under under suspicion
and we're the target right now the 7-5
is the main gig they're looking at so
now i'm sitting here saying i want to
leave i want to become a politician i
can't my name is dirty
life for me
was one big
intense
i mean i've used the word dichotomy
again but it was one big tense
ball of
rubber bands just waiting to snap
and
i ended up
i ended up uh being pursued by a
lieutenant
and and i was plotting on how i was
going to kill him like this is this i
was planning on how i was going to kill
this lieutenant who was pursuing me
because now i i've made an arrangement
with the local drug kingpins to get 8
000 a week it was less stressful because
i wasn't robbing local street dealers
anymore i had a a high level
kingpin giving me 8 000 a week it was
much common my life was way calmer
so and then of course at this point i'm
starting to enjoy cocaine
so i'm getting eight thousand a week
splitting it with my partner who
deserved none of it just for the record
and and
and i'm getting my fill of cocaine and
i'm either selling it or using it mostly
selling it but you know i i do a half a
gram a day
every day
for years
so
so i had that going on so my life was so
like i said i made that decision at some
point i'm all in
so then i end up with the corvette i
drive a brand new red corvette to the
7-5 precinct i park it in lieutenant
spot because he's pissing me off all
right he's after me now what if you're
after me and i put a brand new
vet in your spot with a 38 000 price
sticker on the window and i'm making
27.5
at this point
you think you could catch me
and if you can't catch me guess what
it's on and i'll tell you the truth from
that moment that they didn't pull me in
i'm like i'm golden i can do what i want
i like like that's how the mind works
the mind doesn't say okay sir you've
gotten away with it it's time to go lay
it down maybe that's the insecurity in
me from being a little little guy when i
was when i should have been a bigger man
physically
but now i'm a big guy
powerful guy with money i'm like [ __ ]
the world right it's almost like my
revenge came out
and
rather than being intelligent and
intellectual about it saying okay mr
dowd you've gotten away with quite a bit
in your life it's time to turn over a
new leaf which i attempted it didn't
work for me didn't work for me so i went
back to being a little bit of a crazy
[ __ ] in fact i became emboldened
by it
they when they came after me instead of
quitting the police department i went
off to a rehab center
i went off to a rehab center three times
they called in the pd they called it the
farm i went off to the farm so you know
basically it is a farm you go to this
house in the mountains and you go up
there and you dry out you straighten
your life out you get your head back
together you come back and you
and you'd rejoin the team fresh but not
me because no one would accept me
straight they wanted the corrupt michael
dowd because as a straight police
officer that meant i was working for the
man and they didn't no one no one wants
a guy working for internal affairs in
fact
the irony of this whole story is that
the story about the cop that
no one knows
but i do the cop that threatened to kill
me
that story became who i was to the other
police officers the the the guy who
contacted internal affairs and no one
wanted to work with me now
so here's a guy me who's one of the most
corrupt police officers in the street
i drop a dime on a guy who's trying to
get me fired because i didn't answer to
his yo yo yo
i dropped a diamond him selling crack
which is really a good police officer
right think about it a good police
officer drops a dime on someone selling
crack
now i'm a bad police officer cause i
dropped the dime on some guy selling
crack
okay so i was selling crack i was a bad
cop i dropped the dime on a cop selling
crack i'm a bad cop when am i a good cop
so
i embraced the whole [ __ ]
bad end of it
and i became
more creative i ended up doing two years
in this rehab center
they call the farm
uh i come out of that like more aware
and so now i go to another precinct
called the 94th precinct so i leave the
7-5 i do the two-year stint on the on
the lamb they caught them the farm no
guns they call the rubber gun squad for
those of you listening i was in the
rubber gun squad for two years and i'm
like this is great i don't want i don't
want my guns back i'll just i'll go out
this way you know
no
not the nypd
they call me in one day and they go okay
it's been two years
i go and
can can i get my pension like this
disability pension because i'm crazy and
leave no no no we're going to give you
your guns back and you're going back on
the street as a patrolman and you're
going to go but we're going to shift you
to to the 94th precinct which is a
slower priest of course i find all the
action
of course i find all the action in the
slow precinct i'd become the most
corrupt police officer ever to be in the
94th precinct now instead uh i end up
doing racketeering things with with
organized crime i end up uh
making money uh in in the auto industry
i end up making false police reports out
for people in the auto industry i end up
being
chasing cars
every car accident that took place now
cops don't like paperwork i think anyone
would probably know that anybody knows
that knows a cop we hate paperwork i
would pursue paperwork now because that
paperwork was going to get me anywhere
between 500 a thousand dollars just to
make the report out in benefit to my uh
tow truck guy so i i ended up turning
that into a money machine so
this guy said to me dad why don't you
like resign i go resign
i'm making 2 3 000 a week plus my salary
now i mean i found ways to make money
and i mean i mean it's humorous and it's
embarrassing at the same time i hope you
understand that i i tell these stories
with the same vigor in which i
approached uh what i did but the reality
is i was a scumbag
what i was doing was scumbagish you know
people might even not fault me for
wanting to make a few extra dollars but
the way i approached it was it was about
me it was never about what i was hired
to be a police officer serving the
public i turned it very early on to
serving me and and i i had that approach
throughout and and it's selfish
and in that selfishness
i ended up losing
myself
uh the the guy that was building
wheelbarrows at 15 years old and selling
them to the neighbors as a planter and
it was 15 i paid five dollars for that
wheel that they put on that little wheel
cart that you see out in front of
people's lawns i paid five dollars for
that i took the wood from crates that
were skids that you would that you would
put boxes on top of i took the crate
wood and i molded them and i cut them
and i put them together and i sold
wheelbarrows to my neighbors that's the
guy i was creative a little bit a little
handy trying to have some fun and now
i'm a big involved with kingpins shaking
them down taking payoffs
and eventually
the end would come
so now i'm in the 94th precinct uh and
and and i've turned
i've turned a career uh from from from
being involved with drug uh operations
to
um in the 94th region i got involved in
with organized crime figures and i
turned i turned the uh the auto industry
into a way of making money and
and and it was it was less
i was less involved with the street
level activity then because now i'm just
i'm just dealing with the organized
crime figure who runs a um runs an auto
body repair shop
and but part of me couldn't stay away
from the drugs mind you at this point
i've developed a significant
drug organization on long island okay
and by that i mean significant it was a
funded
it was it was it was not large but it
was it was it was a steady flow it was
anywhere between a thousand to two
thousand dollars a week of steady income
coming in my direction from the four or
five outlets that i provided cocaine to
on long island i mean i'm
entrepreneurial right i i figured these
are gentlemen that i know that go to the
local bars that i would go to
and in those local bars there's always
someone selling cocaine so it might as
well be my cocaine i mean if you're
going to sell cocaine i'm going to bring
in 96 pure cocaine
and you're going to do whatever you do
to it but you know you're getting the
best when i show up so i give my guys
the best cocaine in america at the time
mostly pink peruvian which was
incredible cocaine if you liked cocaine
i don't know if you did or you didn't
but some have some of us have dabbled
and that was always the best it tastes
like bazooka
bazooka bubble gum it was so smooth
that's what they in fact that was one of
the nicknames for it was bazooka
um
but that being said so i provided a good
quality cocaine to my local guys one guy
who owned a liquor store i mean these
were these were businessmen one guy was
a liquor store one guy was a trucker
another guy was um
uh he was also the clown at parties that
was one of the one of his jobs that he
did and the other guy was um an
electrician so all these guys were
established
in their own little fields and they had
a network of people that adults
that they dealt with you know i love
that story when they say you're
poisoning the children you know your
drugs are hitting the going to the
children in the schools well
i'm not going to say that my drugs did
or didn't i know but but from what i
know that wasn't what happened with it
so i'm trying to save my the little bit
of soul i have left for the depredation
that i that i provided to the world
through my own uh
immoral uh activities
that being said you know if you're
getting a half a gram in the back of a
bar on a friday night uh you're not the
child that's getting cocaine okay can we
just can we all be honest with that and
and come to terms that everybody that
sold drugs in their lifetime didn't sell
it to a kid in high school all right i
mean
at least that's my approach i live with
it every day
um
so in the 94th precinct i become the guy
that no one wants to work with because
now i've survived numerous
investigations i've been dumped from one
precinct to another and i end up
involved with the guy that was arrested
for murder so here i am i'm the most
corrupt police officer on the job at
this point i'm known as it
you they don't know why i even have a
badge and a gun on but i do in fact the
commander the precinct commander called
me in the day i got there and said i'll
lock you up myself if i if you do
anything illegal here he says i have
friends in internal affairs who told me
all about you
and i'm looking at this guy like why do
i have a [ __ ] job then
i mean really think about why do i have
a job you gave me my gun and badge back
a shield you gave me my gun and shield
back i was happy in the white stone
pound pushing cars you know invoicing
the vehicles i really don't want this
job like this you let us retire me
because you know that's the options they
had so they didn't want to retire me so
they gave me my gun and my badge back
and they let me loosen the street but
we're watching you
oh you can only watch me so well let me
tell you yeah i'm
a little slick so i made my moves
and and i i think i spoke about this
earlier in this in this in this
interview here that i decided if they're
not going to stop me
i can't stop myself because no one would
accept me as a good cop they wanted me
to
be that edgy rogue guy
so i justified my actions from there
forward and i got involved with a local
colombian in the ninth floor of course
there was only there wasn't a big drug
spot the 9-4 but they had significant
cocaine it was the 80s in the early 90s
so i knew the colombian drug dealer in
the neighborhood of course i found him
and i got kilos from him
and uh
so one so so i'll fast forward to the
day so rodney king verdict comes out and
la which we're we're happy to be in la
right now probably close to where this
uh whole thing broke
la verdict comes out
the cops aren't guilty and la goes on
fire they're called that the riots are
on right
and so that was
may 5th or 6th may 6th
may 6th uh i get i get i get a call
report back to the precinct
i look at my partner he looks at me
you don't often get a 10-2 it's called a
10-2
and it's actually become famous since
since i've coined this it's become you
don't want to get a 10-2 like people
that's become a thing in the nypd you
don't want to get that 10-2.
so
i said how about i call they go no 10-2
because that is so 10-1 or 10-2 i said
how about a 10-1 they're going to know
10-2.
i didn't like the way they answered that
question
so i look at my partner i said did we do
anything wrong today
because that's the first thing you think
why would they tend to you
and they hadn't called us for two days
on the radio like they never call us
now the night four's a quiet precinct
but to not be called for two days
i look at him he looks at me as did we
do anything wrong today why that we
should be concerned i'm i'm seeing them
following me i'm seeing them following
me and i'm not telling my partner
because they follow me all my life
i don't want my new partner to get
spooked we're starting to make money now
we just made we just made fifty four
thousand dollars between me him and ken
urel who's
the other part to my story that we
haven't really spoken about here
we made 54 000 in like a week and a half
so i just we just split up the money
so i don't want to spook him we're doing
really good right but meanwhile being
followed
so i'm like this isn't looking good so i
look at him i go did we do anything
wrong today
he goes what do you mean i go well why
would they be 10-2 in us i said we did
give kenny and his kenny a half a kilo
just now
but that's not wrong i mean i mean
i mean how wrong is that i mean i just
went like this
i mean so i'm not saying i'm not
thinking i'm not thinking investigation
wrong i'm thinking did we run over did
we run over anybody did we smack someone
on the side of the head we shouldn't
have we just had an absolute seven
this big
that's not really wrong i mean what's
the pink they sent me back to the farm
for drinking hmm i did just do a couple
of bumps but that's not really one
because no one saw me do a couple bumps
so i got a little bit of cocaine in me
and about four ounces of vodka i ate
good and so no we've done nothing wrong
we've done absolutely nothing wrong here
today but what people don't know because
i never really share this story is i see
i see a [ __ ] camera in a window above
my head
and i don't say anything because i don't
want to spook my partner
across the street was a church
and the what you would call the where
the lay people in the church live or the
or the priests bang boys whatever they
do up there you know when they hide boys
in the church they're up there they're
up there in the window there and they
got a camera
pointing towards the store that i just
walked out of
i'm saying
i so so here i am
denying what's going on
i'm denying it to myself and to my
partner because i don't want him to know
what he doesn't see i don't want to
spoken for
they call us ten two
we drive down and this is the first time
i've driven the wrong way on meseroll
street mesaros streets are one way it
goes from franklin it goes towards the
water instead i come in from the water
and head towards franklin on messerol
and the priest is on the right-hand side
it's an old beautiful building old
precinct new york style you know with
the with the green windows and the it's
really pretty cool
you don't want to be in there though but
and to my left i see a vehicle that i've
never seen before and that's one of the
things i've been aware of for the last
four years
always check for on
vehicles that i had never seen before
because that's
listen for four years that's how i lived
can you imagine going to work looking
for police vehicles that you've never
seen before and then we get a new
vehicle assigned to the command cause
the old one was thrown out and for about
a week i'm not sure what the [ __ ] this
vehicle is doing here i mean this is how
i live my life i'd be driving down uh
the l.i.e and i'd be in the i'd be going
90 but instead of in the left-hand lane
i go to the right-hand lane because if i
crashed i would crash off the side of
the highway that's the way i went to
work for over a year and a half if i
crash because my body would freeze from
one side all the way down to my foot
so i guess they would call it stress to
say the least right so here i am 30
years old
so stressed out that my body is numb on
one half and so and i'm fading as i'm
driving this stress is so bad i'm fading
as i'm driving
and and i would i would say okay i don't
want to hurt anybody else so if i crash
i crash off to the side of the road i
mean that's that's how deep seated
the depredation is you just don't give a
[ __ ] you can't stop you can't stop
yourself
so
some real relief will come
belief does come
how does relief come to a guy who's
doing what he's doing to himself and
others
i walk into the precinct and the guys in
the car sitting there to get out and so
now i know there's people walking behind
me and i'm walking up these steps into
the precinct very nice very nice
building
so i walk in and and i know something's
way wrong
i look to my right and the sergeant
behind the desk is
looks like
looks like he's seen
three ghosts not one he's like
and i go what's up sarge
and he goes
he points the captain wants to see you
this is like stage they staged it right
and he's panicking the sergeant's
panicking
of course i don't know this at the time
but i as as i as i look back later on
he's panicking
the captain wants to see you he points
so i turn around and the two guys that
were walking in behind us
there's no captain wants to see us they
pull out their badges internal affairs
division
and i'm like yeah that's gonna help i
just drank
another five ounces of [ __ ] vodka i
just did a couple of bumps
yeah can i help you
they go we're here to take you for a
department-ordered drug test for
suspicion i go
oh really this is good
this should work out just fine i'm
saying to myself
so and my partner and i both of us so
we go we go downstairs go to get changed
i'm getting changed and
i'm turning my lock i'm looking at these
guys and i go
is this am i under arrest
no no no i said okay so i open the i
open my lock i take it off
i hope for the thing now i've got
cocaine
i've got cocaine
and and my guns in my locker
and and the pants i have has cut and i
have about a thousand dollars in cash
what cop on on a wednesday or something
that gets paid tomorrow has a thousand
in cash in their locker so i go okay so
i go like this
i i can't get my pants off because
they're so close to me i mean they're
like this they're like touching me so i
go do you mind so they go like this
they back up about three inches
so i
i work my way out of my pants
i hang up my uniform pants i take my gun
belt i hang up my gun belt and i go
okay now i look right look
i'm not under arrest right no okay
so i take my club now i'm looking at
these jeans the jeans have five grams of
cocaine in the pocket
so now i no i'm like okay let me just
put my cocaine laced pants let me get my
pants with the cocaine on so i can't
they won't they won't get like i'm
getting dressed like this trying to get
my jeans on right i put my jeans on and
i and i look at my guns i look at them i
go
what about my off-duty gun do you think
i should leave it like
yeah you probably should
no cop ever leaves his off-duty service
revolver off-duty gun in his in his
locker so i leave the gun in the locker
i said you know this isn't going to go
too well i can tell right now so i go
i'm not under arrest right no so i turn
i can't even turn they're so tight on me
and i'm going okay there's five and a
half grams of cocaine in this pocket
that garbage pail over there that's
where this is going as i walk i'm gonna
go like this i'm gonna dump it right i'm
slick i can do it guess what
as i turn the corner to go to the
garbage pail someone stands in front of
the garbage pail like this
so as i meet and then every place i went
every place i went
for the next
45 minutes
i was blanketed
i mean these guys
if they weren't first of all most
internal affairs cops are pretty are
pretty shitty at being cops all right
but they were good at this
i give them damn good credit the guys
that came for me
they kept me from being able to so i get
in the police vehicle right and i get
they say come on
think about this ladies and gentlemen i
am now
not in custody
but because i am trained to follow
orders
i'm following the orders of police
officers in the civilian world
they're telling me what to do
instead of saying to myself which i was
why don't i just leave
why don't i just leave i'm not under
arrest i can quit the job
anytime i want i can say i'm done i'm
going home but i don't i follow waters
like a good little soldier i get in the
back of a police unmarked police vehicle
while in the back i go
you guys uh look there's no handles
there's no window handles there's no
door handles i'm like even the back of
my police vehicle that i drive around
has door handles and
and and and window handles for the even
for the perpetrator if he wants to get
out
but not in this vehicle this police
vehicle that carries corrupt police
officer that does not have a handle or
or or a window crank
so i said to the officers in front
listen you guys mind if i smile i'm not
handcuffed so i'm free i'm a free human
being you guys mind if i smoke a
cigarette and i'll go right ahead i'm
smoking like a banshee dog like i'm
smoking up the whole car i think i go
you guys want to open nah we'll be okay
they won't open the window
i mean it's a 20-minute drive to where
i'm going they're smoking then i i put
the cigarette out i lit another one i'm
filling up the car with smoke you guys
mind you know i i can't breathe back
here nah that's all right we'll open it
when we get there
i'm saying son of a [ __ ]
because i of course was going to toss
the drugs out the window of the of the
car
so i feel okay perfect i'm gonna get out
of the car at lefrak city if anybody
knows lefrak city in queens on junction
boulevard right by the l.i.e that's
where the police do their uh
uh it's their medical office now
you have 40 000 employees so the medical
office is big enough like a hospital so
it's so big for the cops to go in and
out of anyway
i get out of the vehicle and they got me
blanketed and i turn and i face the
entrance way to left right city uh the
building in lefrak city and there's
60 cops
lining the walkway
all in
gold
everybody's got gold something on on
this side and this side i said oh jesus
i'll never get rid of this [ __ ] now i'm
not gonna eat it right so
and all i'm thinking is
i'm getting the drug ordered a
department ordered police piss test i'm
gonna burn the test and go i'm gonna
fail but hey we'll see
so i'm walking down the phalanx and then
i make a into the building i make a
right-hand turn and that's phalanxed
right to the elevator it's flanks with
people so i don't know this is 148 men
internal affairs 148 men were there
this was big i didn't know how big it
was i'm finding out later on when i read
the news but anyway so the elevator
opens up
and i go up to the 16th or 17th floor i
enter the elevator and there's these
scrambled eggs that i never saw in my
life on there with the scrambled eggs in
the police department means the gold
brass on top of the
their hat the bridge the brim of their
hat
chief so and so chief so and so there
was two chiefs on the elevator one on
one side and one on the other side of me
i don't see chiefs in my old i'm on the
job maybe from a distance oh there's a
chief over there i got two chiefs
standing on the elevator with me they
hit the button the elevator goes up
opens up there's another phalanx of cops
sitting there in on the 16th or 17th
floor and here comes the lieutenant
who said the son of a [ __ ] was after me
for years he comes out
officer doubt
i got lieutenant hoffman or whatever
holmen i think holdman or something like
that lieutenant holman how he is i'm
drunk by the way i'm half drunk now from
drinking the [ __ ] vodka
and he goes
i have a piss test for you i go no
problem sir
i fill this thing up i go okay job over
i close it up i give it i don't say
anything of course i'll give it back to
him and then all of a sudden
one adam but yeah we you got the pet
yeah we got him and we got the package
uh you got it yeah okay good officer
dowd turn around you're under arrest
suffolk county police department
detective
civility whatever
my cousin my mother's cousin
my mother's cousin's arresting me and so
he knew he goes oh i think i know you i
said yeah i think you do he followed me
for he'd been following me for about six
months okay he knew who i was of course
he didn't actually i got the word
believe it or not i got the word early
on they're looking at you
of course i didn't stop i couldn't stop
like i told you when i led into this
part of the story the relief would come
so
i pissed in the cup
i knew i was losing my job
and then suffolk county detective
puts the badge up just turn around
you're under arrest for conspiracy to
distribute narcotics
they reach in my pocket they pull out a
bag of cocaine i've been trying to get
rid of this cocaine now for two hours i
can't get rid of it i look at the guy i
go what are you doing putting cocaine
what are you doing putting cocaine in my
pants he looks at me he goes uh don't
try that with me down
i said everybody tried it with me over
the years i figured i'd try it with you
anyway so
p.s i end up
getting arrested obviously from there
being taken from
from new york city
being taken out to suffolk county new
york and put into riverhead county jail
which by the way i don't recommend to
anybody you talk about a sewer back then
it was a real sewer today a little
different i had a recent use for them
but but uh
back then it was i mean
the toilets were painted the seats were
painted you wanted a clean toilet seat
there was layers of paint that was the
seat like you sat on paint chipped paint
anyway so that was just to give you an
example of what it was like but anyway
so now i'm in suffolk county jail but on
the way to the suffolk county jail i was
so relieved
it was the best feeling i've had since
high school
the house how sad is this
it's the best feeling i had since high
school
since winning
the uh
uh the hockey we won the hockey
championship in high school which which
i was a big part of
uh
mostly my brother and my brothers uh my
neighbor were they it was they were they
were one and two i was number three on
the team they were younger and better
what does that tell you so i really i
took a little bit of a slow approach but
i did win the championship and the
feeling and the exuberance of the
freedom and then the power that came
with that win of the championship was
the same way i felt in the back seat of
the patrol car
when i was formally arrested going out
to suffolk county of course arriving in
the jail is a little different story you
know mentally now you're going through a
lot of emotional changes and oh my god
what do i face
but so i called home that night and my
wife says to me i just want you to know
the next day i just want you to know i
had the best night's sleep in my life
last night
i went excuse me she goes don't take it
the wrong way she says i love you she
says but i slept like a baby last night
she says i finally knew where you were
so so not like like so if you to
capitalize someone's life
you know
i mean to see it from other people's
perspective
you know it was significant for to me
for me to hear i never forgot what she
said right she said i had the best night
sleep in my life so
when i look back at my life and i
analyze it because i think at this age
i'm 61 now we try to analyze what what
what what went wrong and where it went
wrong you know there's several phases
right stages and phases um so
for me i feel as though looking back at
my life
i was one of seven children and i wanted
to stand out i wanted to be you know
daddy see me daddy you know you know
that type of thing and and those
impressions as a young child
form us into who we become
later on in life and of course there's
always things along the way that will
will help tilt us in one way one
direction my mother wanted me to stay in
accounting school
i might have robbed banks or something
differently with a pen but and i might
not have right i might have been a
wonderfully successful accountant or
something or maybe a ceo of a
corporation you know people that have
our type of skill set they end up
actually thriving in society if they
direct it the right direction you know i
didn't um
i i attribute some of that to laziness
to be honest with you i think there's
there's a lazy nature in some of us and
some of that to me was my laziness
or or
i life was oh life was good enough
but when i was at the good enough stage
it was never good enough if that makes
sense it's good enough but had i made
changes in my life it could have been
way way better or more fulfilling and
but today if you don't mind me saying my
life is way more fulfilling today you
know i speak a lot i try to encourage
people not to do what i've done
you know i've been through the aaa i've
been the sobriety process i i've had a
couple of bumps in my road even since
coming out um i think every bump in the
road makes us a better person i don't
know if your audience would agree with
that but it gives us character you know
the person who's never had any
adversity in their life you know had to
overcome anything it's hard to get an
example although
if you start out like them and stay like
them you don't need any examples but if
you have an example of crisis in your
life it's nice i get a lot of calls
today from police officers that are
going through some heavy [ __ ] i mean
ready to put the gun to their heads in
their mouths and you know often now i i
i get involved in uh there's a podcast
like um
that deals with police suicide um
i i get involved with them i i go to
meetings with people i um i go to
colleges i go to high schools i speak
before them so today
the tragedy of my life i don't know what
kind of tragedy they would call it but
you know
i wasted a lot of my life but i think
when i look back it's really not a waste
because i'm able to take all the
travails of my life and put them in
perspective and help the next guy
and and i hope that that message
because when i tell stories and i get a
little stupid and goofy about what what
i've done
i tell those stories from the heart
because
i mean i didn't i robbed drug dealers
and and sold drugs because it was
exciting
i wasn't sad when i was doing it i was
sad when i reflected upon it so when i
tell you a story about how i did it and
why i did it i don't try to tell you
from a
you know a demure position i'm certainly
i i you know i shook down guys like 8
000 a week i i want you to understand 8
000 wii's exciting
the problem is the price you pay is long
lasting i still don't have a real job
i had i had a job
it took me nine years to get a real job
after coming out of prison
and then i was there a year and the
movie was released a documentary about
my life and i lost that job because the
documentary was released you know so so
i will
warn your viewers that you know
especially if you're in a police field
you lose the community of police and and
guys that and women that are in the
police field and guys and women that are
friends with people in the police field
they know
when a cop loses that connection it's a
lonely feeling
and to be honest with you other than the
damage i did to my children
and of course my parents who had to
suffer their son being this this public
disgrace
losing that police family is is huge
because you don't just lose the police
family you lose those that love police
officers and first responders and you
lose that whole community of belonging
to that so if you talk about the
suffering of a person
that has made poor decisions
their suffering continues on throughout
their life what i try to do is i try to
be bold and say this is who i am this is
what i've done
but this is what i've done it's not who
i am
and
if you don't like me that's i i i'm sad
for you because you're missing out today
i feel i have a lot more to offer people
than i did when i was a police officer
because i have so much experience on
both sides of the fence
that i can actually help enrich a police
department
one scandal in your police department
you wish you hired me president
consultant
you know for a couple thousand dollars
to come in and speak to your police
officers and and the change i can make
in one i've had cops call me up and say
i retired because of you
i had new city police officers call me
up and told me they retired because of
me and they still got arrested and then
called me up later on and told me that
if it weren't for me and my example they
would have been arrested on the on the
job and lost everything instead they got
their pensions i got arrested some of
them and others
were in the midst of some of the things
that i will describe if you follow me
about temptation and how to avoid
certain things so and i get those calls
and and it's and it's really
those are the things to me today that
can help me
in my road to redemption right i mean i
think life is is a there's a bunch of
travails and and and and a process but
if you get a chance to give somebody
live a life of redemption
it's what can bring it make it whole
when when i go to when i
they put on my tombstone they'll corrupt
this and that
but
that that that butt is still being
developed and i hope that butt is a good
one and i i ask people to uh
to embrace the butt
you know
and i don't mean the butt
incredible story thank you so much
you